The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
So today we're going to
talk about the system called
Native Client, which is
actually a real world
system used by Google.
One example, they actually
use it in the Chrome browser
to allow web applications to
run arbitrary native code.
It's actually a
pretty cool system,
and it's also an illustration.
Another isolation or sort
of sandboxing or privilege
separation technique,
that's called software fault
isolation, doesn't rely
on operating systems
to sandbox a process
or virtual machines.
But instead, it has a
very different approach
to looking at the particular
instructions in a binary,
to figure out whether it's
going to be safe to run or not.
So before we I
guess start looking
at the technical details of
the system, let's figure out,
why do these guys actually
want to run native code?
So the particular
context they are
interested in applying
their solution to
is a web browser,
where you can already
run JavaScript code and
maybe Flash, and maybe
a couple of other things.
Why are these guys so excited
about running raw x86?
It seems like a step backwards.
AUDIENCE: Really
fast computation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's one
huge advantage of native code.
Even though it might be
unsafe from some perspectives,
it's really high performance.
And whatever you can
do in JavaScript,
presumably you could just write
the same thing and assemble it,
and it'll go at least as
fast-- probably much faster.
Any other reasons?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Run existing code?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So another big
thing is maybe not
everything is written
in JavaScript.
So if you have an
existing application--
I guess 'legacy' in
industry terminology--
if you have some existing
code that you really
want to run in
the web, then this
seems like a great solution.
Because you could just
take an existing library,
like some complicated graphics
processing engine that's
both performance sensitive
and lots of complicated stuff
you don't want to
re-implement, then
this seems like a good solution.
Anything else-- if you're just
like programming a new web app,
should you use
Native Client if you
don't care about legacy
or performance so much?
Any other reasons?
I guess another-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: You don't
have to use JavaScript.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
an awesome reason, right?
If you don't like
JavaScript, then you
don't have to use it, right?
You can actually use, well,
C, if you are so inclined.
You could run Python code,
you could write Haskell,
whatever you think is useful.
You could actually support
other languages all of a sudden.
So this is a reasonably
compelling list of-- motivation
for them to run native
code in the browser,
and it turns out to be
reasonably tricky to get right.
And we'll look at the
technical details, I guess,
of how it works in a second.
But just to show you guys what
this paper is talking about,
I just want to show a
very simple tutorial demo
almost that I got out of
their Native Client website.
It's fairly simple as it turns
out to just take a C++ or a C
program and run in the browser.
So just to show you
what this looks like,
here's basically a demo
I mostly sort of took
from one of their examples.
So you can look at a web page
like this index HTML file.
And inside of it, you have
a bunch of JavaScript code.
And the reason this
JavaScript code exists
is to sort of interact with
the Native Client piece.
So the way you can sort of think
of this running in the browser
is that you have the
browser-- well, we'll
talk much more about
web security later,
but roughly you have some
sort of a page, web page that
contains some JavaScript code.
And this runs with
the pages privileges.
And this can do various
things to the web page
itself, maybe talk to the
network in some circumstances.
But what Native Client
allows you to do
is to have this Native
Client module running
sort of to the side in
the browser as well.
And the JavaScript
code can actually
interact with the Native Client
module and get responses back.
And what you see
here in this web page
is the little bit
of JavaScript code
that's necessary
in Native Client
to interract with the
particular NaCl module
that we're going to be running.
And you can send
messages to this module.
The way you do it is you
take this module object
in JavaScript, and you
call it postMessage.
And you could actually
supply a message
to send to the
Native Client module.
And when the Native
Client module responds,
it'll run this handle message
function in JavaScript.
And in this particular
case, it just
pops up and alerts
dialog box in my browser.
So it's a fairly simple
interface from the web page
side, from the JavaScript side.
And the only thing you
additional you have to do,
is you actually have to
declare this Native Client
module this way.
So you just say embed
module with a particular ID.
And the sort of most
interesting part
is this source equals Hello.
some NMF barch attribute.
And this one just says, well
here's the roughly executable
file that you need to
load and start running
in the native side of things.
And this native code actually
looks like any other C++ code
you might write roughly.
So here's the program.
The interesting part is roughly
this handle message function.
So this is a C++ class, and
whenever the JavaScript code
sends some message
to the native code,
it'll actually
run this function.
And it'll check if the message
that's being sent is hello.
And if so, construct a
reply string of some sort
and send it back.
It's fairly simple stuff.
But just to be
concrete, let's try
to run it and see what happens.
So we can actually build
it, and run a little web
server that is going serve up
this page and Native Client
module.
So here I can go to
this URL and here we go.
Right, it's actually
loaded in the module.
The module seems to have
gotten our hello message
from JavaScript.
It replied back with the
string back to JavaScript.
And the JavaScript code
popped up a dialog box
containing that response.
So it actually
does kind of work.
We can try to see if we could
crash Native Client-- hopefully
not, but we can take this
code and we have this buffer.
We could write a
bunch of As to it--
I don't know, quite a
lot-- and see what happens.
So hopefully this
shouldn't crash my browser,
because Native Client is
trying to provide isolation.
But let's see what happens.
So we can rebuild it,
rerun the web server.
And here if you run
it, nothing happens.
We don't get the
message back anymore,
so clearly the
message didn't get
sent back from the
Native Client module,
because I don't see any popup.
We can look at the
JavaScript console here,
and we can see that the
Native Client module tells us
NaCl module crash.
So somehow it caught this
buffer flow scribbling
over some memory, or maybe
it jumped to some bad address
containing all As.
But any case, the
Native Client module
is actually able to contain
this without this arbitrary
sort of memory corruption
in the module affecting
the rest of the browser.
So this is roughly just a quick
demo of what the system is,
and how you use it as an
end user or web developer.
So let's look now at some more.
So that's all in terms of
demos I have to show you.
So let's look more now at how a
Native Client is going to work,
or perhaps even why we need this
particular design as opposed
to some of the alternatives.
So if your goal, I guess
is to sandbox native code,
there's a number of
alternatives you can make.
People actually
had these problems
before, performance
existing legacy code
and other languages before
Native Client came around.
And people just solved
them in different ways
that maybe weren't as satisfying
from a security standpoint
or usability standpoint
as Native Client.
But it is doable.
So let's see.
So what could you
do if you really
want to run native
code in a browser?
So one option that people did
was to trust the developer.
And maybe a variant
of this approach
is to ask the user whether they
want to run some piece of code
in their browser or not.
So does everybody
understand roughly
what the plan is, right?
Like instead of having that
whole Native Client compilation
strategy, I could
have just built
a simple C program, served
it up on the browser,
and maybe the
browser asked, do you
want to run this site or not?
If I click yes,
then it accidentally
scribbled over the browser's
memory and crashes the browser.
So it's possible, right?
It certainly solves
all these goals,
but what's wrong with it?
Well, I guess there's the
insecurity part, which
is unfortunate.
One way to potentially get
around this-- and some systems
did.
Like Microsoft had
the system called
ActiveX, that basically
implemented this plan.
You could serve binaries to IE,
the browser on your machine.
And as long as it came
with a certificate
from particular developer
signed by let's say
Microsoft or someone
else, then it
would actually run this code.
What do you guys think about
this plan, is this useful?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So right, you really have
to put quite a bit of trust
into whoever it is
that's signing this,
that they will only
sign binaries that
will not to do something bad.
But it's kind of vague
what this bad thing is.
And presumably they're
just writing C code
and signing it blindly without
doing a huge amount of work.
In which case, you might well
be susceptible to some problems
down the line.
What if we ask the user?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like the user's goal
is to run this thing.
And even if the user wants to
be cautious, it's actually not
clear how should
the user decide?
Suppose I really
want to understand,
should I allow this
program to run?
All it tells me is
well, maybe it's
created from Google.com
or Microsoft.com,
and its file name as foo.exe.
I don't know, like
what's in there?
Even if I dissemble
the code, it might
be very hard to tell
whether it's going
to do something bad or not.
So it's actually
really hard to decide.
So one way to think
of Native Client
is it's a mechanism by
which users can actually
get some confidence
whether they should say yes
or not to running this thing.
So in practice, I guess
like Paul Young, who
was giving his guest
lecture last week,
and he suggested that you
should enable this click
to play extension in Chrome.
So every extension,
including Native Client,
you should rush click on this
thing before it starts running.
So in some ways,
that's ask the user.
But then the user
actually has some sense,
that well, if I click
it, I'm still hopefully
safe in the sense that Native
Client will protect me.
So the two aren't
necessarily exclusive,
but you really want
some technical guarantee
from Native Client that ensures
that even if you say yes,
there are something
meaningful that
isn't enforcing your security.
So does this make sense?
OK.
So the other I guess approach
that people have taken,
is to use an OS or hardware
sandboxing, or isolation.
So this is things we looked at
in the last couple of lectures.
So maybe you would use
Unix, isolation mechanisms.
Maybe if you had something
more sophisticated,
if you're running
a free [INAUDIBLE]
maybe you would use Capsicum.
It seems very well suited to
sandboxing some piece of code.
Because you can give it very
few capabilities, and then
it seems great.
And Linux has a similar
mechanism called Seccomp
that we briefly touched on in
the last lecture, that could
allow you to do similar things.
So it seems like
there is already
a mechanism for writing code
in isolation on your machine.
Why are these guys opposed to
using this existing solution?
Then they are like reinventing
the wheel for some reason.
So what's going on?
Yeah?
Oh yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe they want
to minimize the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so in
some sense, maybe they
don't want to trust
the operating system.
So maybe they're here,
and they're actually
worried about OS bugs.
It might be that the previous
dekernel, the Linux kernel,
has quite a lot of C code
written that they don't want
to audit for
correctness, or maybe
can't even audit for
correctness, even
if they wanted to.
And in one of these Capsicum or
Seccomp based isolation plan,
you probably do trust quite
a bit of code in the kernel
to be correct, for the sandbox
to actually hold and enforce
isolation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: As you get a lot more
ways to use browsers and stuff,
like you'd have to deal with
having some sort of thing
you're doing with it on
like iOS and Android,
and all these other
things, accessing--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so it's actually
another interesting
consideration
is that normally
my OSes have bugs.
But actually the
OSs are incompatible
with each other in some
ways, meaning that each OS
has it's own-- like right here.
Well, there's Unix, there's
Capsicum, there's Seccomp,
but this is just
a Unix variances.
There's Mac OS seatbelt,
there's Windows something else,
and the list just
keeps going on and on.
So as a result,
every platform you
will have to use a different
isolation mechanism.
And the thing that
actually bothers them
is not so much that they'll have
to write different code for Mac
and Windows and Linux.
But more of that, this impacts
how you write the thing
inside of the sandbox.
Because in Native
Client, you actually
write a piece of code
that runs the same way,
or it's the same piece of code
the runs on Apple or Windows
or Linux systems.
And if you use these
isolation mechanisms,
they actually impose
different restrictions
on the program being sandboxed.
So you'll have to write
one program that's
going to run inside
of a Linux sandbox,
another program inside of a
Windows sandbox, and so on.
So this is actually
not acceptable to them.
They don't want to deal with
these kinds of problems.
So are there other
considerations?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Presumably
performance as well.
Because if you say
Capsicum, you need
to fork up a set of
[INAUDIBLE], or whatever
is running inside the sandbox.
With here, they can actually
run it in the same [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's true, yeah.
So potentially the
approach they take,
the software fault
isolation plan
is actually highly
performant, and could
outperform these
sandboxes at the OS level.
It turns out that
in Native Client,
they actually use both their
sandbox and the OS sandbox,
just for extra
precaution for safety.
So they don't actually
win on performance
in their implementation,
but they could, right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There is some
like control aspect to it.
Because it can control what
happens in the browser,
but if they sent one out to the
client's machine into their OS,
they sort of don't
necessarily know
what might be happening to it?
PROFESSOR: So I
guess maybe one way
to think of that is that
yeah, the OS might have bugs,
or my OS might not do as good
of a job at sandboxing it.
Or maybe the interface
is a little different,
so you don't know what
the OS is going to expose.
AUDIENCE: So it doesn't
like prevent the code
from doing some bad things.
Like there are a lot
of cases of bad things
that the code can
just do, like maybe
you want to statically
analyze the distance,
but they both sit in a loop
and then not allow that
as a valid program.
PROFESSOR: So you could, right?
So their approach is quite
powerful in the sense
that you could try to look
for various kinds of problems
in the code like maybe
infinite loops, et cetera.
It's hard to decide, kind
of like the holding problem,
whether it's going to have
infinite loops or not.
But in principle, you might be
able to catch some problems.
I think one actually interesting
example that I almost
didn't realize this
sort of existed
before reading this
paper, is these guys
are worried about hardware bugs
as well, that not only are they
worried that the
operating system might
have vulnerabilities that the
motions code will exploit.
But also that the
processor itself
has some instructions
that will hang it,
or it'll reboot your machine.
And in principle, your hardware
shouldn't have such bug,
because the operating system
relies on the hardware
to trap into the kernel if
there's anything bad executing
user mode, so that the operating
system can take care of it.
But experimentally, it
turns out that processors
are so complicated
that they do have bugs,
and these guys
actually say, well, we
actually found some
evidence that this happens.
If you have some complicated
instruction that the CPU wasn't
expecting, the CPU will
actually halt instead
of trapping to the kernel.
This seems bad.
But I guess it's not a
disastrous, if I'm sort of only
running reasonable
things on my laptop.
But it is bad if you visit
some web page and your computer
hangs.
So they want basically
a stronger level
of protection for these Native
Client modules than what
you would get out of sort
of an OS level isolation,
even from a hardware
[INAUDIBLE] bug standpoint.
So they're actually pretty cool.
They're like really
paranoid about security,
including hardware problems.
All right, so any questions
about all these alternatives,
how that works, or
why these guys are not
excited about that?
Makes sense?
All right.
So I guess let's
try to look at now,
how Native Client does actually
decide to sandbox processes.
Let me pull up these boards.
So Native Client takes
this different approach
that's in general called
software fault isolation.
And the plan is actually
not rely on the operating
system or hardware to
check things at runtime,
but instead to somehow look at
the instructions ahead of time,
and decide that there are always
going to be safe to execute.
So actually look at
the binary, and you
check all the
possible instructions
to see whether they're going
to be safe instructions
or unsafe instructions.
And once you've decided that
it's all going to be safe,
you can just jump in
and start executing.
Because you know it's all
composed of safe things,
so it cannot go wrong.
So we'll talk about
exactly what this means.
But roughly what
they're going to do is,
they're going to look at
pretty much every instruction
in the binary code that is
served up to the browser.
And they're going to decide
that particular instructions are
going to be safe or unsafe.
What do they do for
safe instructions?
Well, they're just
going to allow them.
What's an example of
a safe instruction?
What are they thinking of that
don't need any extra checks
or protections, et cetera?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so like
any kind of ALU operation.
Basically you have
math, presumably
moves between
registers and so on.
So this doesn't actually affect
the security of the system,
as far as they're concerned.
Because all they
really care about
is things like memory safety,
where what code you execute,
and so on.
So as long as you are just
computing on some stuff,
and registers, they
don't really care.
It's not going to affect
the rest of the browser.
So what about unsafe operations?
I guess these are
things that they
might care much more about.
So this anything that maybe
does a memory access, or maybe
some privileged instruction,
maybe invoking a system
call on this machine.
Maybe trying to jump out of
the sandbox, who knows what?
So for these kinds
of instructions,
they are going to do
one of two things.
If the instruction actually is
necessary for the application
to do it's job, like accessing
memory seems important,
then they're going
to somehow make sure
that they can execute this
unsafe instruction safely.
Or if you're jumping around
for example in the program's
address space, [INAUDIBLE]
what they're going to do
is somehow instrument
the instruction.
And what instrumenting
the instruction means
is that you used to have
one unsafe instruction that
sometimes does good things, that
the application might actually
want to do legitimately.
And sometimes the instruction
can do bad things.
So what instrumenting
it means is
that you add some extra
instructions before it,
that it'll check or enforce,
but only good things
are going to happen
with that instruction.
So for example, if you are
accessing a memory location,
which you could
do-- it turns out,
they don't do it for
performance reasons--
but one way to instrument
a memory access would
be to put some
checks, like an if
statement before the
instructions, saying, well,
is this address you're
accessing in range of what's
allowed for this module?
And if so, do that--
otherwise, exit.
So that would instrument
an instruction.
And that would turn
an unsafe instruction
into one that's always
safe to execute,
because there's always
that check in front of it.
So does that make sense?
This is their sort of
big idea for running
this enforcing safety without
support from that operating
system at some level.
And I guess for other
unsafe instructions,
they don't instrument
all of them.
Some of them they
actually prohibit,
if they believe that this
is an instruction that's
not really necessary
during normal operation,
and if an application
tried to run it,
we should just kill
the application
or not allow it to run
in the first place.
Makes sense?
Those are their sort of big plan
for software fault isolation.
And once you've checked
the application's binary,
and it all passes,
and everything
seems to be properly
instrumented,
then you can just run the
program and off it goes.
And by definition
almost, it will not
do bad things, if we
do all these checks
and instrumentation [INAUDIBLE].
And I guess there's one more
part to the software fault
isolation story, which
is that once you've
make sure that
everything is safe,
then it can't actually
do anything terribly
interesting, other than
compute stuff in it's
own little memory.
So it can't access the network,
it can't access the disk,
it can't access your browser,
display, keyboard, almost
anything.
So pretty much every software
fault isolation story,
there's actually also some
trusted service runtime.
And this trusted
runtime is going
to not be subject to these
checks on it's instructions.
So the trusted
runtime could actually
do all these potentially
unsafe things.
But this trusted runtime
is written by Google.
So hopefully they
get a [INAUDIBLE].
And it's going to
implement all the functions
that Google's Native
Client team believes
are OK throughout
for these modules.
So these are going to be
things like maybe allocated
memory, maybe creating
a thread, maybe
communicating with
the browser as we
saw-- so some sort of a message
passing system, et cetera.
And the way it's going to be
exposed to this isolated module
is through certain presumably
special jumps or operations
that the module is going
to perform to transition
control into this
trusted runtime,
but hopefully in a very
predictable way to-- question?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious about, you
have to design this application,
knowing that it's going
to be sent to the NaCl module?
Or does it like change
the code to [INAUDIBLE]
making the [INAUDIBLE]
sort of stuff bad?
PROFESSOR: So I think if you
are building an application,
you do have to be sort
of aware that it's
going to be running
inside of Native Client.
So some function calls like
malloc or pthread_create,
I think they just transparently
are placed with calls
to their trusted runtime.
But if you do anything
like opening a file
by path name, or anything
else that sort of you
would expect to do
on a Unix machine,
that you would probably have
to replace with something else.
And you'd probably want
to structure your thing
to interact at least a little
bit with your JavaScript or web
page in some way.
And that you would have to do
by explicitly doing some message
passing or RPCs into
the JavaScript part.
So that you would have
to probably change.
So there are some-- it's not
like you can run an arbitrary
Unix program in there, and
you'll just sort of get a shell
and you can run commands
all of a sudden.
Probably if you
tried hard, maybe you
could create such
an environment.
But by default,
you probably have
to make it operate inside
of this web page, and then
[INAUDIBLE].
Does that make sense?
All right.
OK.
So that's the overall plan
software fault isolation.
So I guess let's
look at actually
what safety means in their
case for Native Client.
So we talked loosely
about this notion
of safe instructions, unsafe
instructions-- what do
they actually care about here?
So as far as I can
tell for Native Client,
safety basically
means two things.
One is that there's no
disallowed instructions
that it can execute.
And these disallowed
instructions
are things like maybe
system calls or triggering
an interop, which is another
mechanism on x86 to jump
into the kernel and
invoke a system call,
and probably other
privileged instructions that
would allow you to escape
out of the sandbox.
We'll look a little
bit more later
at what instructions
could actually
let you jump out of a sandbox.
And in addition to this no
disallowed instructions rule,
they also want to make sure that
all code and data accesses are
in bounds for the module.
So what this means,
is that they actually
dedicate a particular part
of the program's address
space-- specifically
it goes from zero up
to 256 megs in the process.
And everything that this
untrusted module does
has to refer to locations
within this chunk of memory
in the program.
All right, so just
to double check.
So why do they want to
disallow these instructions?
So what if they fail to
disallow the instructions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The module can
manipulate the system.
PROFESSOR: Right, so that's
fairly straightforward,
exactly, yeah.
So it can just directly
reboot the machine
or open your home directory
and enumerate all the files,
and do all these things.
So that seems like
a good thing to do.
Why do they care
about this plan,
like isolating the coded
data to only access
these low addresses?
What goes wrong if
they fail to do that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Then they can sort
of accessing and interrupting
[INAUDIBLE] module
on the computer.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We don't care if
they ruin their own program
and it crashes.
That's fine, as long as it's
not going to crash the key
to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so in
some sense, that's true.
But in their case, they
actually run the thing
in a separate process.
So in theory, this would only
crash that extra process.
I think that I guess what
they're really worried about
is that this is a
necessary condition
to ensure this no disallowed
instructions in some way,
because there's other
stuff, like this trusted
runtime in your process.
So if what you really
care about is not
corrupting the rest
of your computer,
then if the untrusted
module can arbitrarily
jump into the trusted
service runtime
and do anything that the
trusted service runtime can do,
then they could sort of
violate this property.
So in some ways, this is really
like a supporting mechanism
for enforcing that.
In principle, this could also
be used for lighter weight
isolation if you could run
this Native Client module
inside of the browser
process itself, and not
start an extra process.
But it turns out for
performance reasons,
they really have to
tie down the module
to this particular
range of memory,
or it has to start
at zero anyway.
So this means that
you can only have
one really Native Client
untrusted module per process.
So you probably are going
to start a separate process
anyway.
Makes sense?
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there
actually a reason
why it has to start at zero?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so it turns
out it's more efficient in terms
of performance to
enforce jump targets,
if you know that the legitimate
address is a contiguous set
of addresses starting at zero,
because you can then do it with
a single AND mask, where
all the high bits are one,
and only a couple of low
bits are zero-- well,
if you're willing-- well--
AUDIENCE: I thought the AND
mask was to ensure [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so the
AND mask ensures alignment,
you're right.
So why do they start at zero?
I think it probably
helps them to-- well,
I guess they rely on the
segmentation hardware.
So in principle,
maybe they could
use the segmentation hardware
to shift the region up,
in terms of linear space.
Or maybe it's just
with the application,
sort of sees this range.
And you can actually place
it at different offsets
in your virtual address space.
It could be-- yeah, so
maybe you could actually
play tricks with the
segmentation hardware
to run multiple models in
a single address space.
AUDIENCE: But is it because they
want to catch a null pointer
reception?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so they want to
catch all points of reception.
But you could sort of do that.
Because the null
pointer-- I guess
we'll talk about
segmentation in a second,
but the null pointer actually
is relative to the segment
in which you are accessing.
So if you shift
the segment around,
then you can map
an unused zero page
at the beginning of
everyone's segment.
So yeah, it might be that you
could do multiple modules.
I think for-- well, because
one reason they probably
want to do this
is that when they
port their stuff to
64 bits, they have
a slightly different design.
This paper doesn't
really talk about it.
And I think about 64-bit
design, the hardware itself
got rid of some of the
segmentation hardware
they were relying on
for efficiency reasons,
and they have to do a much more
software oriented approach,
in which case having a
little bit doesn't help them.
But in this 32-bit version, I
think, yeah, maybe that's true.
That's not a deep reason
why it has to start at zero.
Other questions?
All right.
So I guess we sort of roughly
understand what the plan is,
or what we want to enforce
in terms of safety.
So how do we do this?
So let's look at some of
at least naive approach,
and see how could
we screw it up,
I guess, and then we'll
try to fix it afterwards.
So I guess the
naive plan that sort
of looks like what they
do, is to just look
for disallowed instructions by
just scanning the executable
from the start going forward.
So how do you detect
that instructions?
Well, you could just
take the program code,
and you sort of lay it
out in a giant string that
goes from zero up to maybe
all the way to 56 megabytes,
depending on how big your code
is, and you start looking.
OK, well, maybe there's
a nop instruction here.
Maybe there's some sort of
an add instruction there.
Maybe there's a not-- I don't
know, some sort of a jump,
et cetera.
And you just keep looking.
And if you find a
bad instruction,
you say, ah, that's
a bad module.
And then you discard it.
And if you don't see any system
call [INAUDIBLE] instructions,
then you're going to
allow this module to run,
module or whatever it is we'll
do for the in bounds checks.
So is this going to work?
So why not?
What are they worried about?
Why is so complicated?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the instructions?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so the weird thing
is that x86, which is the sort
of platform they are targeting
has a variable
length instructions.
So this means that
the particular size
of an instruction depends
on the first few bytes
of that instruction.
So you have to actually
look at the first byte
and say, OK, well,
the instruction
is going to be this much more.
And then maybe you sort of have
to look at a couple more bytes,
and then decide, OK, well,
that's exactly how long it's
going to be.
But you don't know
how ahead of time.
So some architectures like
Spark, ARM, [INAUDIBLE],
have more fixed
length instructions.
Well, ARM, for example--
ARM is like weird,
but it has two
instructions lengths.
Either everything is two bytes
or everything is four bytes.
But x86, the instructions could
be like one byte or 10 byte
or five bytes, anything
in between, as well.
I forget actually how big.
You can get a pretty
long instruction.
I think you can get like a
15 byte instruction with x86
if you try hard.
It's complicated
instructions, though.
But as a result, the
problem that could show up
is that maybe you're
scanning linearly
and everything seems to be fine.
But maybe at runtime,
you'll actually
jump into the middle
of some instruction.
Maybe it was a
multi-byte instruction,
if you interpret it starting
from the second byte,
it looks like a completely
different thing.
So that's just one example
of sort of playing around
with an assembler.
And if you have an instruction
like this, 25 CD 80, 00, 00.
And if you interpret it as
this five byte instruction,
meaning that you
look at this byte.
And oh yeah, this is going to
be a five byte instruction.
So you have to look
five bytes forward.
And then this turns out to be
a fairly benign instruction
that's an and of
the EAX register,
with some particular constant
that happens to be I think 00,
00, 80, CD. anyway.
So this is one of
the safe instructions
that Native Client should just
allow under the first rule
in checking these
binary instructions.
But if it turns out
at runtime the CPU
decides this is where it has
to start executing the code,
then this instruction
is actually
a four byte instruction, and
its actually an int instruction
that makes the OX80
interrupt, which
is one way to make
system calls in Linux.
So if you miss this fact,
then eventually you're
going to allow untrusted
module to jump into the kernel
and make system calls, which
is what you wanted to prevent.
Make sense?
So how can we prevent it?
Like one possibility
is like maybe we
should try to look
at every byte offset.
Because at least x86 can only
start interpreting instruction
on a byte boundary
instead of a bit boundary.
So you like look at every
single possible byte off,
and you see what
instruction starts there.
Is this a reasonable
plan to report?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I mean, what
if someone actually
is doing an and, and they're
never going to jump into that.
And now you're just
allowing their program.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so basically it's
prone to eventually
false positives.
Now if you really wanted
to, you could probably
contort yourself and
change the code a little--
and somehow avoid this.
If you knew exactly what
the checker was looking for,
you could potentially
change these instructions.
Maybe like end it with
one thing first, and then
end it with another mask later.
But just avoid these
suspicious byte patterns.
But that just seems
pretty awkward to do.
Now it is actually possible
that the architecture does
involve changing the compiler.
So in principle, they
do have some component
that actually has to
compile the code correctly.
You can't just take
of the shelf GCC
and compile a code
for Native Client.
So in principle it's doable.
But I think they're just
thinking it's too much hassle,
and it's not going to be
reliable or high performance,
et cetera.
Make sense?
And plus there's a couple
of x86 instructions
that are prohibited or should
be unsafe and prohibited.
But they're like one
byte long, so that
is going to be pretty damaging
to look for or filter out.
OK.
So if they can't just assemble
and sort of straight up
and hope for the best, then
they need some other plan
for doing this disassembly
in a reliable fashion.
So what is that client
or Native Client
to ensure they don't get tripped
up by this variable length
encoding?
So I guess one way to
think about it is, well,
so how are we going to solve
this reliable disassembly?
So in some sense, if we
really do scan forward
from the left to the right, and
we look for all the possible up
codes, if that's the
way the code executes,
then we're in good shape.
So even if there are
some weird instruction
and has some
offset, then the CPU
isn't actually
going to jump there.
It actually executes
the same way
that we're scanning
the instruction
screen from left to right.
So the problem with getting
the disassembly to be reliable
really comes from the
fact that there's jumps.
Because if we execute linearly
from left to right, then
the CPU will follow
the same rules
that our checker is following,
and see the same instruction
screen.
So the problem really
comes down to what
happens if there's a jump
somewhere in the application.
Could a jump to some
position in the code
that we didn't observe in
our left to right scan?
So this is what they are
sort of going another
in the reliable disassembly.
And the basic plan is to just
check where all the jumps go.
It's actually fairly
straightforward at some level.
They have a bunch of rules
we'll look at in a second,
but roughly the plan is if
you see a jump instruction,
then it actually
has to be-- well,
you have to check that the
target was seen before.
So you basically do
the left to right scan
that we sort of described
in our naive approach here.
But then if you see any
kind of a jump instruction,
then you see what is the address
to which the jump instruction
is pointing to, and
you make sure that it's
an address that you saw in
your left to right disassembly.
So if there's a jump
instruction for example
that goes to that
CD byte, then we're
going to flag that jump as
invalid because we never
saw an instruction
starting in the CD byte.
We saw a different instruction.
But if all the instruction,
if all the jumps
go to the start of
instructions we saw,
then we're in good shape.
Does that make sense?
So the one problem
is that you can't
check the targets of
every jump in the program,
because there might
be indirect jumps.
For example in x86,
you could actually
have something like jump to
the value of that EAX register.
This is great for implementing
function pointers.
The function pointer
somewhere in memory,
then you hold to
function pointer
into some register at one time.
And then you jump
to whatever address
was in the [INAUDIBLE]
relocation register.
So how do these guys deal
with these indirect jumps?
So I have no idea if
this actually going
to jump to the CD
byte or the 25 byte.
What do they do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The
instrument [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is their basically main
trick here, is instrumentation.
So whenever they see
a jump like this,
well actually what the
compiler is going to generate
is a proof that this
jump is actually
going to do the right thing.
And the way they actually
do this is-- they
don't actually know--
it's actually kind of hard
to put in a proof here that
it's one of the addresses
that you saw during the
left right disassembly.
So instead what
they do is they want
to make sure that all the jumps
go to multiples of 32 bytes.
And the way they
do this is actually
change all the jump
instructions into something
that they pseudo instructions.
So they're still that
jump to the EAX register.
But they prefix it
with an AND instruction
that is going to
clear the low five
bits, E 0 with an EAX register.
So that AND instruction
clears the low five bits,
which means that it
forces this value
to be a multiple of
32, two to the five.
And then you jump to it.
So if you look at it
during verification time,
then you can sort
of convince yourself
that this instruction
pair will only
jump to a multiple 32 bytes.
And then in order to make
sure that this is not
going to jump to some
weird instruction,
you're going to enforce
an extra rule, which
is that during your disassembly,
when you're scanning
your instructions
from left to right,
you're going to ensure that
every multiple of 32 bytes
is a start of a
valid instruction.
So in addition to
this instrumentation,
you're also are going to check
that every multiple of 32
is a valid instruction.
What I mean by valid instruction
here is an instruction
that you see when you
disassemble from left to right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why 32?
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah, so
why did they choose 32?
That seems like
some magic number
that they pulled out of a hat.
Should you choose 1,000 or five?
Any comment?
OK, should we choose five?
So why is five bad?
AUDIENCE: The power of two.
PROFESSOR: Yes, OK, so
we're on a power of two.
OK, so good point.
Because otherwise ensuring
something is a multiple of 5
is going to require a
couple of instructions here,
which is going to lead overhead.
How about eight?
Is eight good enough, yeah?
AUDIENCE: You can have
instructions longer than eight.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK, so
it has to be at least as
long as the longest x86
instruction you want to allow.
So if there's a ten
byte instruction,
everything has to be a
multiple of eight, well,
you're kind of screwed with
a ten byte instruction.
There's nowhere to put it.
So it has to be
at least as long.
32 is pretty good, like
the biggest I could find
was 15 bytes.
So it's probably good enough.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can [INAUDIBLE] be
longer than [INAUDIBLE] code,
they'd have to have
a alt instruction
at the beginning
of the [INAUDIBLE]
so you can't just jumpt
directly into [INAUDIBLE]
and they also need a
jump instruction that
jumps to another [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right, yeah.
So you have to be able
to fit for the entry
and exit from the
process service runtime,
you need to be able to fit
some nontrivial amount of code
in a single 32 byte slot.
We'll see how this
works in a second.
Or even 31 bytes slot,
as you are pointing out,
for one hold instruction.
Should it be much larger?
Should we make it, I don't know,
a thousand byte, well, 10 24?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sparse,
because you have to have
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if you
have a lot of function pointers
or lots of sort of indirect
jumps, then every time
you want to create some place
where you're going to jump to,
you have to pad it out
to the next boundary
of whatever this value is.
So with 32, maybe that's OK.
You're like well, worst
case, you waste 31 bytes,
because you just need to fast
forward to the next boundary.
But if it's a multiple of 1024,
then all of a sudden you're
wasting a kilobyte of
memory for an indirect jump.
And if you have probably short
functions or lots of function
pointers, then
this might actually
be a memory overhead all
of a sudden, as well.
Does that make sense roughly?
So yeah, I think the
32 is not set in stone.
Like Native Client has
to have 32 byte blocks,
but something on that
order probably works.
16 is probably a little short.
On the other hand,
like 64 could work.
128 maybe is getting
a little longish.
But I don't think
you could derive 32
from first principles.
Makes sense?
All right.
So let's set a plan for
reliable disassembly.
And as a result, the compiler
has to be a little bit careful
when it's compiling your C or
C++ code into a Native Client
binary.
It has to basically
follow these rules.
So whenever it
has a jump, it has
to add those extra
instruction front.
And whatever it's
creating a function
that it's going to jump
to, our instruction
is going to jump to,
as we're talking about,
it has to pad it out.
And it can't just pad
it out with zeros,
because all those have
to valid up codes.
So it actually has to pad
it out with [INAUDIBLE]
just to make the
validator happy,
just to make sure that every
possible instruction is
a valid one.
And luckily on x86, no
op is a single byte,
or at least there is a no
op-- that's a single byte.
There's many no ops on x86.
So you can always pad
things out to a multiple
of whatever this constant is.
Make sense?
All right.
So what does this
guarantee to us?
I guess let's make
sure that we always
see what happens in terms
of the instructions that
will be executed.
So this finally
gets us this rule.
So we can be sure there's never
a system call being issued.
What about-- So
this is for jumps.
What about returns?
How do they deal
with the returns?
Can you return for a
function in Native Client?
What would happen if you
ran into a red hot code?
Would that be good?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
don't want the-- [INAUDIBLE]
modifying your
overall [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, it's true
that it pops the stack.
But the stack that Native
Client modules use,
it's actually just some data
inside of their section.
So you don't actually care--
the Native Client contact
doesn't care whether those
guys screws up their stacks,
overflow their stack, or--
AUDIENCE: Wait, but you could
put anything on the stack.
And when you [INAUDIBLE]
you jump through that--
PROFESSOR: That's true.
Yeah, so return is almost
like an indirect jump
from a particular
weird memory location
that's at the top of the stack.
So I guess one thing
they could do for return
is maybe prefix it with a
similar check, where maybe like
pop the top thing of the stack.
You check whether it's
valid, and then you write,
or you somehow do an
AND to a memory operand,
and that's the top of the stack.
It seems a little
fragile, partly because
of race conditions.
Because for example, if you
look at the top location
of the stack, you
check that it's OK,
and then you do a write
later, another threat
in the same module
could modify the thing
at the top of the stack.
And then you'd be
referring to that address.
AUDIENCE: Would this not be
the case for the jumps as well?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so what
happens with the jump?
Could our race conditions
somehow invalidate this check?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The code
is not writable.
PROFESSOR: Well the code is
not writable, that's true.
So you can't modify the AND.
But could another thread
modify this jump target
in between these
two instructions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's in
a register, so--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's the cool thing.
There is basically-- if
it modifies it in memory
or where ever it loaded
into EAX from, sure,
you do it before you load, in
which case this EX will be bad,
but then will
clear the bad bits.
Or it could modify it
after, at which point
it's already in the
EX, so it doesn't
matter that it's modifying
the memory location from which
the EX register was loaded.
And threads don't actually
share the register sets.
So if another thread
modifies the EX register,
it will not affect this
thread's EX register.
So this instruction
actually is sort of
race-proof in some sense.
Other threads can't invalidate
this instruction sequence.
Make sense?
All right.
So here's another
interesting question.
Could we bypass this AND?
I can jump around in this
address space all I want.
And when I'm disassembling
this instruction,
this seems like a perfectly
fine parallel instruction,
an AND and a jump.
And the check for static
jumps is that, well,
it just has to point to
some target that was seen.
So yeah, we saw an AND.
That's one instruction
that's valid.
We saw a jump, that's
another valid instruction.
So when I see a
direct jump up here,
maybe I jump to some address.
I don't know, one,
two, three, seven.
That's actually OK, even though
it's not a multiple of 32.
Native Client doesn't
generally allow direct jumps
to arbitrary
addresses, as long as
that address is a instruction
that we saw during disassembly,
as we were just talking about.
So could I put in this very
nicely checked indirect jump,
and then later on in the code
jump to the second instruction
in that sequence?
So then I'll load
something into EX,
jump here, and
then directly jump
into this unsandboxed address.
That will violate
the security, right?
Does everyone see that?
So how is this avoided?
AUDIENCE: Well, the NaCl
[INAUDIBLE] and the jump
has to signal instruction.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this
is why they call this thing
a single pseudo instruction.
And even though
at the x86 level,
they're actually
distinct instruction,
as far as the NaCl
validator thinks of it,
it's actually a
single atomic unit.
So as far as this check for
whether it's an instruction
that you saw before,
they think, oh, this
is the only instruction
that I saw before.
Jumping in the middle
is like jumping
in the middle of this guy.
It's the same thing.
So they basically enforce
slightly different semantics
than what x86 enforces in terms
of what an instruction is.
And this might
actually mean that you
can represent certain
instruction sequences in NaCl.
So if you actually had
legitimate code that
looked like this
before, this is going
to be turned into a
single out code in NaCl.
But hopefully that's
not a problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Presumably
they can out that
in the trusted code base in
the start of the text segment.
Because that way, you will
always replace those two.
Instead of putting those in the
binary that you produce anyway,
you just jump straight to
that jump target that's
in the privileged section.
PROFESSOR: In the trusted
runtime, you mean or something?
AUDIENCE: No, so
in the first 64 K--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they had
these trampolines and yeah--
AUDIENCE: So they can make
that one of the trampolines.
Except that it doesn't jump out.
It jumps back in.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So that
way, it wouldn't
need to be a super instruction.
It would just be
a single x86 jump
into there, which would
then jump out again.
PROFESSOR: That's true, yeah.
That's another sort of clever
solution that you could do,
is instead for the
deliverance of [INAUDIBLE]
so suppose that you didn't want
to do this pseudo instruction
trick, and you just wanted
to have a single instruction
replacing the jump EAX.
Well, what you can
basically come up
with is a library of all
possible indirect jumps
you can ever do.
So like well, there is jump EAX,
there's jump EBX, and so on.
And you would construct
a library of these guys
for each of them, you would
construct the safe check
that you'd want to
replace them with.
So for this one, you'd put an
AND in front of it, and so on.
And for this one, you'll also
put an AND in front of it,
and so on.
And then in the compiled
binary, every time
you want to jump to EAX,
what you actually do,
is actually jump
to a fixed address
that corresponds to this
helpful piece of code
stored somewhere in that
low 64 k of the program.
And then this guy will do
the AND and jump again.
The reason that they
probably don't do this
is performance for this
sort of interesting reason.
So that Intel processor,
actually most processors
these days, have
to predict where
the branch goes to keep the
pipeline of the processor
full at all times.
It's one of the really
complicated branch predictor
that not only decides whether
you're going to branch or not,
like if statements.
But also actually guesses
where you're going to jump.
So if you see an indirect
jump, it actually
is going to guess what the
address is going to be.
And this is actually
a guess that's
stored per cache line stored
in the jump instruction.
So if you have a single
place where all the jump
EAXs come from, then
the CPU is always
going to be very confused.
Because these jump EAXs seem
to be going all over the place,
everywhere.
Where as if we are really
tied to a particular jump
instruction, it would
be a better prediction.
That's just a performance
trick that they play.
Make sense?
All right.
So I guess we roughly
understand how
it's going to
disassemble all of these
instructions how it's going
to prevent these instructions.
So now let's look
at the set of rules
they are going to enforce
through this table
in the paper, table one.
And it has all these different
rules for the validator
to follow, or that the
binaries have to follow
and the validator checks.
So I'll go through these
rules and just double check
that we understand why
all these rules are there.
So we have these things,
C1, all the way to C7.
So C1 basically says that once
you load the binary memory,
then the binary is actually
not writable at the page table
level.
So they set the permission
bits for the binary
can be non-writable.
So why?
It should be fairly
obvious hopefully.
The reason is that
their whole security
plan relies on them checking
that your binary is correct.
So once they've
checked it, they want
to make sure you can't
modify the binary
and have it do something
illegal that they prohibited.
So this is I think
reasonably clear then.
So C2 is their plan
that basically has to
linked at zero at start at
64 K. So this requirement,
I think doesn't actually have
to do with security so much.
I think it's just
for convenience,
because they just want
to have a standard layout
for the program.
In some sense,
it's for simplicity
so that they don't have to deal
with complicated relocation
records, which
means that there's
fewer things that the validator
or a loader might screw up.
But basically this is sort of a
standardization plan for them,
in terms of how to
load their executable.
Make sense?
All right.
So the third requirement is that
I guess the indirect jumps use
the two instruction.
So the two instruction
is this thing above.
So that, we just talked about,
why it needs to ensure this,
so that you don't jump to the
middle of some instruction,
or somehow invoked
[INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
Make sense?
All right.
So what's going on with C4?
Basically you have to pad out
two page boundary with a halt
instruction.
Why do they want to pad
their binary out with halts?
Any ideas?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think--
so I have to admit,
I don't have a crisp
answer for why C4 exists.
But I think it's
roughly what you
are saying, which is that
if you-- the code naturally
stops at some point.
There's some end to it.
And the question
is, what happens
when you just keep executing
it, and you get to the end?
Then the processor might just
keep executing past the end,
and execute some
extra instructions.
Or maybe it wraps around
in some weird way.
So they just want to
make sure that there's
no ambiguity about what
happens if you keep running
and you don't jump, and
you just run off the end
of the instruction screen.
So let's just make sure
that the only answer there
is if you keep
executing, you'll halt,
and you'll trap
into the runtime,
and you'll terminate the module.
So it's just sort of about
simplicity and safety,
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't think there's a concrete
attack that I could have
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But here's the thing.
You can't jump past the end.
So the last thing
that you could jump to
is the last instruction.
And by this rule, that
instruction must be hold.
So you could jump to the hold,
but then would be at the hold.
And you want to
run past the end.
So I think it's just
sort of cleanliness,
as far as I can tell, a
guarantee for them to make sure
that there's no
weirdness in terms
of wrap around at the engine.
All right?
So C5 is basically
no instructions
that span the 32 byte boundary.
So this is sort of a
variant of this rule
that we talked about before,
where every multiple of 32
must be a valid instruction
that we solder in disassembly.
So otherwise, we'll jump to
the middle of an instruction
and have the problem
with that sys call
that might be hidden there.
OK.
And then we have C6, which
is basically all instructions
reachable by disassembly
from the start.
So this ensures that we
see every instruction,
and we can check every
instruction that could possibly
be run at runtime.
And I guess C7 is this
basically all direct jumps.
OK.
So this is the example of
that jump up there, where you
code in the target right away.
So it doesn't have
a multiple of 32,
but it still has to
be a valid instruction
that we solder in the
left to right disassembly.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So what's the
difference between C5 and C3?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think C5 says that
if I have an instruction
that's multiple bytes, it cannot
stay on that 32 byte boundary.
So suppose that I have
my instruction stream.
And here's an address, 32.
Here's address 64.
And maybe I have some
sort of an AND instruction
that sort of spans
this boundary.
So this is what C5 prohibits.
No instructions can
span this boundary.
Because otherwise, we
saw this AND instruction.
But because you can always
jump 32 byte multiples,
you could jump into
the middle of that.
And who knows what
will happen there?
So this is what C5
prohibits for that.
And C3 is the counterpart
to it on the jump side.
So C3 says that
whenever you jump,
you're going to jump to
a multiple of 32 bytes.
And C5 says that everything you
can find in a multiple of 32
bytes is a safe instruction.
AUDIENCE: I wonder if
there's any redundancy
because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I don't know.
I'm not sure.
I had a little bit of that
feeling when reading this list.
It seems like, wow,
they're all good rules.
But I'm not sure it's the
minimal, non-orthonormal set
of-- or set of orthonormal rules
that you need to enforce this.
But any other
questions about the set
of restrictions they have?
All right.
So I guess let's think
about this homework question
that we sort of assigned.
It turns out-- I think
there was actually
a bug that Native
Client had and that's
in our sandbox at
some point, which
is that for some
complicated instruction,
I believe they didn't have
the length encoding correctly,
if I remember
properly, in which case
something bad might happen.
I can't remember exactly
what the bug was.
But suppose that the
sandbox validator
gets the length of
some instruction wrong.
What bad things could happen?
How would you exploit this?
AUDIENCE: You can hide a
sys call or a [INAUDIBLE]
potentially.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So suppose that there's some
fancy variant of some AND
instruction that you
could write down.
And maybe the validator
gets that wrong
and thinks that, oh,
this guy is actually
six bytes, when in reality,
it's five bites long.
So you could plop this
down, pull this AND down.
And then the validator
thinks, oh, it's six bites.
I'll look six bites further.
And I'll check whether this
is a valid instruction.
And we just have to
make sure that whatever
is six bytes later looks
like a valid instruction.
But the CPU itself,
when it runs this code,
is going to maybe only look
five bytes from the AND
because that's the real
length of the instruction.
So if we can use this extra
byte to stick a sys call
instruction, then we
could be in business.
So if we stick that-- remember
from that example above on x86,
OXCD is how you make
an AND instruction.
So if we stick a CD byte
at the end of that AND,
then maybe we can
put something here
that looks like an
instruction but actually is
going to be part of the
AND instruction here.
And then we can all of
a sudden make a sys call
and escape the inner sandbox.
Makes sense?
Any questions?
So the validator
in Native Client
has to be really
in sync with what
the CPU is doing because it's
sort of guessing, well, here's
exactly how the CPU is going
to interpret every instruction.
It has to be right
at every level here.
So that's going to be a
little bit tricky to do right.
But there are actually
some other interesting bugs
in Native Client that
people have found.
One, I think, has to do
with not properly sanitizing
the environment of the CPU when
you're jumping into the trusted
service runtime.
I guess we'll talk
about this in a second.
But the trusted
service runtime is
going to basically run
with the same sort of set
of CPU registers initially
that the untrusted module was
running with.
So if there's something
that it forgets
to clear or reset or whatnot,
then the trusted service
runtime might be tricked
into doing something
that it wasn't meant to
do, or the developers
didn't want to do it initially.
OK.
So let's see.
Where are we now?
So what we understand
now is roughly
how we can disassemble
all the instructions
and how to prevent
disallowed instructions.
So now let's look at, how do we
keep the memory and references
for both code and data within
the bounds of the module?
So for performance reasons,
the Native Client guys actually
start using some
hardware support
at this point to make
sure this actually
doesn't impose much overhead.
But before we look at the
hardware support they use,
does anyone have any suggestions
for how we could do it actually
without any hardware support?
Could we just enforce
all the memory accesses
going in bounds with the
machine we have so far?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can
instrument the instructions
to clear all the higher bits.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
So actually we see that we have
this instruction over here,
which every time
we, for example,
jump somewhere, right now,
we clear the low bits.
But if we want to keep all
the possible code that you're
executing within
the low 256 Megs,
then you could just
replace this with a 0.
So we end with 0ffffe0.
So this clears the low bits and
also caps to at most 256 Megs.
So this does exactly what
you're sort of suggesting
and would make sure that
whenever you're jumping,
you're saying within
the low 256 Megs.
And the fact that we're
doing disassembly,
you can also check for
all the direct jumps,
that they're all in bounds.
And that's actually not so bad.
The reason I think they
don't do this for code
is because in x86 you can very
efficiently encode an AND where
all the top bits are 1.
So this turns out
to be, I think,
basically a 3 byte
instruction for the AND,
and a 2 byte instruction
for the jump.
So the overhead is,
like, 3 more bytes.
But if you want to
have non-1 high bits,
then this is actually now a 5
byte instruction all of sudden.
So I think they're worried a
little bit about the overhead
here.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Isn't there
also the problem
that you might have
some instructions which
increment what version
that you're trying to get?
So you might say--
your instruction
might have a constant offset
or something like that.
PROFESSOR: Well, I think, yeah.
You would probably
prohibit instructions
that jump to some complicated
formula of an address.
So you will only support an
instruction that jumps directly
to this value.
And this value always
gets ANDed and--
AUDIENCE: It's more for
memory accesses rather than--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's a good point
because this is just code.
And for memory access, there's
lots of weird ways on x86
to refer to a particular
memory location.
In that case, you basically
have to first compute the memory
location, then insert an extra
and, and then do the access.
And I think that's the real
reason why they're actually
very worried about the
performance overheads
of this instrumentation.
So on x86, at least
on the 32-bit, which
is what this paper talks about,
they actually use some hardware
support instead to
limit the code and data
addresses that the untrusted
module can refer to.
So this actually leverages
some somewhat esoteric hardware
in x86.
So let's see what it looks
like first before we start
figuring out how
we're going to use
it to sandbox the next module.
So this hardware is
called segmentation.
It's sort of left over
from the days before x86
actually even had paging.
So the way it works is actually
there's a segmentation on x86.
They way it works is that
whenever a process is running,
there's actually a table
maintained by the hardware.
Let's call it the
segment descriptor table.
And what this table has is
just a bunch of segments,
numbered from 0 up to
whatever the size of the table
is, kind of like file
descriptor in Unix.
Except every entry
has two values in it,
some sort of a
base and a length.
And the same for every
entry, base and length.
OK.
So what this table
does is it tells us
that we have a
couple of segments.
And whenever we refer to
a particular segment, what
this in some sense
means is that we're
talking about a chunk of memory
that starts at address base
and goes for this length
from that base upwards.
And the way that
this actually helps
us to enforce memory
bounds is that on x86,
every single instruction
in one way or another,
whenever it's
talking about memory,
actually talks about
memory with respect
to a particular
segment in this table.
So for example, when you
actually do something like move
a memory value from a pointer
stored in the EAX register
into maybe another
pointer stored in the EBX
register, what you think it
does is it figures out, well,
what's this address?
It knows the memory
at this address.
And then it figures out,
OK, what's this address?
And it stores the value there.
But in fact on x86, whenever
you're talking about memory,
there's an implicit--
what's called a segment
descriptor, which is kind of
like a file descriptor in Unix.
It's just an index into
this descriptor table.
And unless specified
otherwise, every opcode
has a default segment in it.
So when you're
doing a move, this
is actually relative to the DS
or the data segment register.
So it's like a special
register in your CPU
that's a 16-bit integer,
if I remember correctly.
And that 16-bit integer points
into the descriptor table.
And the same here.
This is actually the relative
to that DS segment selector.
Actually, a bunch of these guys
are 6 segment selectors on x86.
There's a code selector
CS, DS, ES, FS, GS, and SS.
And the code selector
is sort of implicitly
used to fetch the instructions.
So if your instruction
pointer points somewhere,
it's actually relative to what
the CS segment selector says.
And most data references
implicitly use either DS or ES.
And then FS and GS are
some special things.
And SS is always used
for the stack operations.
If you push and
pop, they implicitly
come off of this
segment selector.
It's a fairly baroque
machinery, but it turns out
to be hugely useful for
this particular use case
because what happens is if you
access some address at maybe
some selector DS: some offset
or some address here, what
the hardware will actually do
is translate it into-- well,
it'll put this
address, and it'll
add the table of DS,
the base to this guy.
And it'll actually
take the address modulo
the length from the same table.
So whenever you're
doing a memory access,
it's actually going to have the
base of your segment selectors,
sort of descriptor table
entry, and take your address
that you're actually
specifying and mod it
with the length of the
corresponding segment.
Does this make sense?
It's a little baroque, but
that's what [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So why isn't
this used, for example,
for buffer protection?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's a good question.
So could you use
this for protecting
against buffer overflows?
What's the plan?
You could basically set up--
for every buffer that you have,
you could put the
buffer's base here.
You can put the size
of the buffer there.
AUDIENCE: What if you
don't need to put it there
before you want to write to it?
You wouldn't need
it there constantly.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think the reason
that this isn't
used so much for protecting
against buffer overflows
is that this table has at
most 2 to the 16 entries
because these descriptors
are actually 16 bits long.
And in fact, a couple of the
bits are used for other stuff.
So in fact, I think you can only
stick 2 to the 13 entries here.
So if you have more than 2
to the 13 variable size array
things in your code,
then it's probably
going to overflow this table.
That was actually
a little bit weird
for the compiler to
manipulate this table
because the way you
actually manipulate
it is through system calls.
So you can't actually
directly write to this table.
You have to issue a system
call to the operating system.
And the operating system
will pull this table
into the hardware for you.
So I think most
compilers just don't
bother having this complicated
story for managing buffers.
Multex actually did this though.
So on Multex, you
actually kind of have 2
to the 18 distinct segments and
2 to the 18 possible offsets
within a segment.
And every possible
shared library chunk
or chunk of memory was
a distinct segment.
And then they would
all be range checked,
not maybe at the variable level.
But still.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Presumably,
it's also a bit slower
if you have to tap into the
kernel all the time to--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah.
So there's also the overhead.
I guess to set this up,
there would be some overhead.
Or if you create a new buffer
on the stack, all of a sudden,
you have to call in to
this guy and add an extra.
So yeah, it is nice machinery.
But it's mostly used
for coarser grain things
because of the overhead
of changing it a bit.
Makes sense?
All right.
So how many of these
guys actually use
now the segmentation machinery?
Well, you can sort of
guess how it works.
I guess by default all
these segments in x86
have a base of 0 and a
length of 2 to the 32.
So you can access the
entire range of memory
you could possibly want.
So for Native Client, what
they do is code in a base of 0
and a length of 256 Megs.
And then they point
all these six segment
selector registers to this
entry for a 256 Meg region.
So then whenever the hardware
does a memory access,
it's going to mod it.
The offset was 256 Megs.
So it'll be restricted to the
256 Meg range of memory that's
allowed for the module
to [INAUDIBLE] modify.
Makes sense?
All right.
So I guess we sort of roughly
understand now this hardware
support and how this works and
how you could eventually do
the wealth segment selectors.
So if we just
implement this plan,
is there anything
that could go wrong?
Could we escape out of
the segment selector
in the untrusted module?
I guess one thing
you have to watch out
for is that these registers are
just like regular registers.
And you can actually move
values in and out of them.
So you have to make sure that
the untrusted module doesn't
tamper with these registers,
the segment selectors,
because somewhere in
your descriptor table
is also the original
segment descriptor
for your entire process,
which has a base of 0
and a length of 2 to the 32.
So if the untrusted
module could somehow
change the CS or DS or
ES or any of these guys
to point to this original
operating system that
covers your entire
address space,
then you could then do memory
references with respect
to this segment and get
out of this sandbox.
So as a result,
Native Client has
to add some more instructions
to this prohibited list.
So I think they basically
prohibit all instructions that
move into a segment
selector DS, ES, et cetera,
so that once you're
in the sandbox,
you cannot change the segment
that you are referencing things
with respect to.
Makes sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The segmentation such
and such provides [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So it turns out that on
x86, the instructions
to change the segment
descriptor table are privileged.
But changing these
indices into the table
are completely unprivileged.
Yeah.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
initialize the table
to put all 0 lengths
in the unused slots?
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
So the unused slots--
you could-- yeah.
You can set the
length of the table
to something so there
are no unused slots.
It turns out that you actually
need this extra slot containing
0 and 2 to the 32 because
the trusted run time is going
to need to run in this segment
and access the entire memory
range.
So you need this entry in
there for the trusted runtime
to work.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] set list?
In order to set the table
output to some length,
do you need to--
PROFESSOR: No, actually.
It's pretty cool.
It was like something that
you don't have any root for.
On Linux, there's
actually a system
called-- I think it's called
modify_ldt for local descriptor
table.
And it lets any process
modify its own table.
These tables are
actually per process.
Well, as everything in x86,
it's actually more complicated.
There's a global table,
and there's a local table.
But the local table
is for a process
you can modify [INAUDIBLE].
Makes sense?
All right.
OK.
So I guess one thing we
could now try to figure out
is, how do we jump in and out
of the Native Client runtime
or out of the sandbox?
So what does it mean
for us to jump out?
So we need to run
that trusted code.
And the trusted code
lives somewhere up
above the 256 Meg limit.
And in order to jump
there, we basically
have to undo all these
protections that Native Client
sets in place.
And they basically boil down
to changing these selectors.
So we already-- I
guess our validator
isn't going to
enforce the same rules
for the stuff above 256 Megs.
So that's easy enough.
But then we need to somehow
jump into the trusted runtime
and reset these segment
selectors to the right values,
to this giant segment that
covers the entire process
address space.
So the way that works
on Native Client
is through this
mechanism they call
trampolines and springboards.
So all these guys
are things that live
in the low 64k of the module.
And the cool thing
about that is that these
are going to be sort of chunks
of code laying at the lower
64k of that process space.
So that means that this
untrusted module can actually
jump there because it's
a valid code address.
It's going to be on the 32
byte boundary potentially.
And it's going to be
within the 256 Meg limit.
So you can jump to
these trampolines.
But the Native Client
runtime is going
to actually copy
these trampolines
from somewhere outside.
So the Native
Client module isn't
allowed to supply its
own trampoline code.
The trampoline code comes
from the trusted runtime.
So as a result, it
actually contains
all these sensitive
instructions,
like moving DS
and CS, et cetera,
that the untrusted code
itself is not allowed to have.
So the way you actually
jump out of the sandbox
and into the trusted runtime
to do something like malop
or create a threat is you
jump to a trampoline, which
lives at a 32 byte offset.
So maybe it's an address.
Well, who knows?
Maybe it's 4,096 plus 32.
And it's going to have some
instructions to basically undo
these segment selectors.
So what it's
probably going to do
is it's going to move some
value-- I don't know, maybe 7--
into the DS register and maybe
some points to this entry here
that's allowed for the entire
2 to the 32 address space.
And then you're going
to effectively move
CS and then jump somewhere
up into the service runtime.
And this is basically
going to be past 256 Megs.
So there's going to be
this jump in here that's
not regularly allowed.
But we're going to be
OK with it because it's
going to be into a point in the
trusted service runtime that
is expecting these jumps.
And it's going to perform
proper checks afterwards
on the arguments and
whatever else that is
being passed around.
And we can actually
do this, move DS here,
because we know that
it's actually safe.
The code we're going
to jump to isn't
going to do anything
arbitrary or funny
with our untrusted module.
Makes sense roughly,
what's going on?
So why do these guys bother
jumping out of the segments?
Like, why not just put the
whole thing in the trampoline?
It seems like more
work on some level.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We only have 64.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you don't
actually have a lot of space.
Well, I guess you have 64k.
So that's potentially maybe
enough for-- maybe you
can move a malop in there.
But the problem is not
so much the 64k thing
but this 32 byte restriction.
And it's actually
not a restriction
on the trusted code,
because the trusted code can
do whatever it wants here.
It's not going to be checked.
The problem is that
the untrusted code can
jump to every 32 byte offset.
So every 32 byte
offset has to be
prepared to be very
special in its arguments.
So you probably are going
to have a hard time writing
this code here
with every 32 bytes
rechecking the arguments
and values and so on.
So basically, you have to
jump out of the trampoline
and into the runtime up here
within 32 bytes of code.
So then if you jump
to the next thing,
then, well, something else
is going to happen here.
But it's not part of this
same trusted routine here.
Makes sense?
OK.
So this is how you sort of
jump out of the sandbox.
To jump back in, you also
need to-- you basically
need to invert these
transformations.
You need to sort of set the
DS back and CS back and so on.
And the tricky thing is that
if you're running outside
of this 256 Meg limit, if you're
running inside of the trusted
run time, then you can't really
reset these registers yet,
because otherwise,
you won't then
be able to access any of the
memory in your space outside.
So what they actually do is
they have this thing called
a springboard, which
is how the trusted
runtime from outside
the 256 Meg limit
is actually going to jump back
into the Native Client module.
So here it's going to reload the
DS register with maybe whatever
that limit in the
segment descriptor is.
Maybe let's say it's 1.
And then it's going
to reset other things,
and then it'll jump
to whatever address
the trusted runtime
wants to return to
in the untrusted module.
Makes sense?
So this is how you
sort of jump back in.
And the only sort
of tricky piece
here is that you don't want
the untrusted code to jump
into the springboard itself.
Maybe something
weird will happen.
Who knows?
So what they do is they
actually put a halt instruction
as the first byte of this
32 byte multiple sequence.
So if you jump to the
beginning of this guy,
you'll immediately halt.
The trusted runtime
is going to jump to
one past this byte
and be able to execute
the springboard.
But this is something that
only the trusted runtime can
do because regularly
checked, this
is not going to be allowed.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Wait.
Is it a springboard in
the untrusted module?
PROFESSOR: So the
springboard is within the 0
to 256 Meg part of
the untrusted module.
But it actually lives
in that 64 bit chunk
at the very beginning
that doesn't actually
come from the binary you
download from some website.
But it's actually
patched into it
by the Native Client
runtime when it first
loads this module into memory.
AUDIENCE: Why not just
have it in the runtime?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So why not have
it in the runtime?
So what happens if the
runtime was allowed
to supply the springboard?
Is this bad?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How would
it know-- how would it
know where to jump back to?
PROFESSOR: Well, I think what
this actually is is it actually
jumps to something like EAX.
So the trusted
runtime says, oh, I
want to return to this address.
It puts it on the EAX
register, jumps here.
The springboard does this, this,
this and then jumps to EAX,
wherever the trusted
runtime's set up to jump.
So what if the module came
with its own springboard?
AUDIENCE: Well, you could do it
as a natural jump type thing.
But it shouldn't know anything
about the descriptor table.
That's a hardware--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So actually, this is a
really important instruction
for sandboxing, the fact that
we reload that descriptor
to point at one of those
limited descriptors up there.
It's really important.
And if the module was allowed
to supply its own springboard,
maybe it'll just skip this part
and then not restrict itself
back to 256 Megs.
So once you jump
through the springboard,
you'll be able to still access
the entire process address
space.
So the springboard is part
of the enforcement mechanism.
It sort of sets
up the boundaries.
So this is the
reason why I think
they don't want the springboard
to come from the developer.
Now-- yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Can you put the
springboard past 256 megabytes?
PROFESSOR: So I
think they don't want
to put the springboard
past the 256 Megs
because then you might
have trouble jumping down.
So you want to jump to
a particular address,
but you also want to set
up extra registers here.
So if you're-- I think this
basically has to-- sorry.
This has to do with setting
that CS code descriptor
segment because you want
to set the code descriptor
segment to this bounded
segment, and you
want to jump to some particular
address at the same time.
So I think it's
easier for these guys
to do it through a springboard
because you first sort of jump
to here.
Then you can set your CS value.
But you can still
execute the same code
you're still running because
you're within the 256 bound.
Makes sense?
I think basically it
has to do with what
atomic primitives the
hardware provides to you.
So basically, you want to set a
whole bunch of these DS segment
selector registers and the CS
register and jump to somewhere
at the same time.
So this is one way
for them to do it.
I think that's maybe
not as [INAUDIBLE].
Probably, if you tried
hard, you could probably
come up with some x86
instruction sequence that
could do it from outside
the bound of the address
space in the module.
Makes sense?
All right.
So I guess that's it
for Native Client.
And I'll see you guys next week.
We'll talk about web
security as far as I know.